for at least 15 years going back to 2005
and maybe earlier but to 2005 that we
can be certain of Joe Biden has publicly
opposed expanding the size of the
Supreme Court to pack it with more
Democrats when he ran for the Democratic
presidential nomination Biden was
consistent just last year he said that
Democrats would quote live to rud that
day if they pack the Supreme Court as
Franklin Roosevelt tried to do in the
30s and had to stop because of backlash
from the public that hated the idea
Biden separately said the court would
lose all credibility
if Democrats did that well yesterday Joe
Biden changed his mind air quotes around
the word mind of course or probably more
accurately his handlers told him to say
something different so he did as whether
he'd support loading the bench with
leftwing activists as Chuck suer has
demanded Biden said it was quote a
legitimate question he then refused to
say whether he supported it or not he
wasn't going to give an answer because
it would quote shift the focus and quote
change the subject from other issues
like whether Donald Trump should be able
to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg change
the subject what other subject is there
Joe Biden is running to be president of
the United States he may not be aware of
that but he is voters once again
overwhelmingly oppose the idea of
tearing down our third branch of
government by packing the Supreme Court
making it a purely political operation
even more than it already is it's a
popular solution in some circles on
Twitter and in the universities the root
of all poison and that's about it
everybody else knows it would destroy
our government it's not even a
controversial point last year Ruth Bader
Ginsburg easily the most left-wing
jurist in Generations acknowledg that
Court packing would wreck the court
watch I have heard that there are some
people on the Democratic side who would
like
to increase the number of
Judges I think that was a bad idea when
President Franklin delanor Roosevelt
tried to pack the court if anything
would make the court appear partisan it
would be that one side saying when we're
in power we're going to enlarge the
number yeah like really what we need to
do in this moment is wreck more of our
ancient institutions please even Ruth
Bader Ginsburg understood that was
insane and destructive but now the
lunatics who order us to follow her
deathbed dying wishes want to ignore her
actual expressed wishes from last year
and without any protest Joe Biden is
going along with it because he thinks
well who knows what he thinks or if he
does if you needed more evidence that
Joe Biden isn't a candidate so much as a
pawn for partisans who are trying to get
back in power at any cost there you have
it for eight days this month by the way
Joe Biden's Handler shut him off from
the Press starting at noon or earlier
than that that is unprecedented in a
presidential campaign with fewer than
two months to go they don't want us to
be able to ask questions of Joe Biden
maybe he can't handle questions even
basic softball questions he has been
getting including from one reporter at
the Washington Post why aren't you angry
at Donald Trump that was an actual
question we don't know why they're
hiding him one thing we do know for
certain if Joe Biden can't even tell us
whether he plans to destroy a branch of
our government he has no business
running any branch of government